[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
sisters and dear friends as you know the
question that everybody asked how did
the universe come into existence
obviously the question is inside this
box and we're going to put this to the
test with this little experiment where
we're going to hit central london
and ask people and discover what's
inside the box
see you guys soon
how the universe came into existence
it's in this box yeah so what we're
going to do is
we're going to open it and we're going
to see what's inside yes
so do you want to go ahead really yes
i'm scared no no there's nothing i
promise you there is nothing i promise
you i promise you
take my word i promise you so this is
also yes it's in there
okay what's in there huh
what's what's inside nothing empty box
okay
the scientists tell us that the universe
came from nothing
do you believe do you believe that i
kind of do yeah yeah
so so what's inside there is caused this
whole universe to come into existence
is do you believe that i believed it now
okay okay okay
can anything come from nothing though
can no it's not no so but then how are
you saying that the nothing inside his
box calls the universe
that's this is not impossible yeah
so so then that means from nothing how
could this whole universe come from
nothing
it must stomach must have created it
yeah yes exactly
yeah do you believe it the universe came
from nothing though yeah of course it
came from nothing and it will blow up
like things start
okay okay okay okay what what the
universe came from nothing is in this
box
[Music]
but uh there's one sorry there's nothing
in the box in a minute yeah so that's
that's the nothing that created the
universe
yeah nothing so this this this nothing
here created the whole universe
apparently so yeah do you actually
believe that no
no okay yeah a couple of weeks ago we
caught the particle which started the
whole universe
yeah so i just need you guys to open it
so we can find out how we're talking
all right today yeah yeah
three two one
will well the thing is science tells us
that
like lawrence crowd says it came from
nothing
yes yeah yeah it's nothing
awesome
okay now what is that something called
the scientists are telling us
it was nothing well but then then again
they say
that nothing is something so what's your
tip for this is just an experiment with
it obviously yeah
no no no i don't think they say it's
nothing they say that it's more of a
condensed
hot soup because from what i even
learned in
[Music]
i understand where you're coming from
yeah but we believe it was the creator
that quotes it by the way
as you know we're probably muslims uh
but the thing is what what is when we
speak to most atheists i don't know what
your beliefs are but they say they say
for example
it was caused by this but we're like
what was that because it has to have a
quote
yeah do you get it so so if there's an
infinite like
back loop right what created this what
created that yeah keep going oh no i
mean
i'm i'm like i'm not i know a lot of
very
obnoxious atheists and i and the sort of
people who i look down are you religious
people
i'm not one i hate that it really pisses
me off because
basically what i use is
[Music]
if you imagine all that is all knowledge
that we could ever know
and the tiny tiny amount that we must
really know how can we assume
anything about anything so i'm not
against any religious idea
what do you think tom tommy's not quite
like i'm always a quiet person i've been
trying different a lot of different
periods studying fitness
with charlie and okay not so much chris
yeah but i hope this is the big bang
thing i find
interesting that it started from a small
thing yeah however i don't see how it's
plausible that everything's so large
after something so small
the particle that started the whole
universe everything that's inside this
universe yeah
is in here are you ready do you want me
to open up you want to open it
don't no no no no no no i promise you
nothing's scary nothing's going to jump
out
no i promise you yeah okay
okay what do you see in the box
[Music]
yeah nothing well do you believe that
nothing started the whole universe yeah
yeah yeah really yes
so so this inside the box started all
the universe
possibly can you explain how no
okay so so what happened to this nothing
that
started whole universe
okay so it can't come from nothing yeah
yeah guys
the whole universe that came into
existence is in this box are you guys
ready to see this yeah
okay do you want to open it yeah open it
all right
okay can you see here one second
[Music]
what's inside nothing
the scientists are telling us that
nothing created everything
do you believe that no no i don't
can nothing ever create something that's
[ __ ] nah say that say that say that
that's [ __ ] you heard that yeah
can nothing ever create anything
i don't think so you can't eat it is
that have you ever heard anything coming
from nothing
it's impossible yeah so what would you
call like what would you say to an
individual who says who believes that
nothing
started everything that was he what
would you describe him as
a stupid person stupid person
now we're going to prove to you the
whole universe that came into existence
the particle is in this box yeah
me yeah yeah okay so whatever cause the
universe is in this box
i'm going to open it for you yeah no
it's not it's not it is it is
it's not nothing okay now now what's
inside the box
nothing okay the sciences tell us that
the whole universe
came from nothing yeah
so so did it come from suffolk or
nothing
you come for something yes it did yes
yes it is
but yeah you can't you can't know this
listen yeah okay
okay i love people
listen i love people love a religion yes
who
actually follow religion yes i hate
people that
[ __ ] follow someone who says i'm
representing your religion yes yes
that's what it is yes
by both sides so so the fact that
scientists tell us
nothing creating the universe would you
believe that or not
i don't believe it i just said that i
just said that okay it come from nothing
can something no no yeah
so god please
was doing the experiment and somebody
got a little bit hungry and the thing on
his diet was paper
so he ate our books you know as you can
see but obviously the experiment
continues and each other let's see what
happens next
okay in here we have the particle that
we captured a couple of weeks ago yeah
okay and this is the particle
is the particle that started the whole
universe yes so do you want me to open
are you gonna open it and by the way
it's nothing that's gonna attack you i
promise you
you can punch my face right here okay
okay
okay what's inside
yes but what can you see i can't see a
lot
is there anything inside yes what's
inside awesomes
okay well what i'm trying to say oh
there's
there's nothing in there yeah so so the
scientists are telling us that the whole
universe came into existence from
nothing
and this is the same nothing that caused
the universe yeah
so do you believe that
i'm not smart enough to know you don't
need to be smart to be honest dude can
you
can you tell me anything that came from
nothing has anything ever appeared from
nothing or created from nothing
but can you imagine hey absolutely
nothing absolutely nothing the afternoon
or can you imagine absolute infiniti
the the universe can you imagine that i
could absolutely yeah you can't imagine
it but the thing is like for example
to say for example infinite in the real
world doesn't really exist because if i
said i had infinite
yeah and if i added one more banana how
much banana do we have well if i took
one banana out
do you get what i'm trying to say so we
have nothing in the box but the the
scientists want us to believe
that this is the same nothing that
caused all universe and everything
inside it to exist
is that something that can be believed
uh
yeah so you believe this nothing in here
calls the whole universe
i haven't got any other explanation for
it okay but just because you have an
explanation does that mean we believe
the most no no no offense like some of
that's
like ridiculous because nothing is
nothing it's the absence
there's nothing so how could something
come from absolutely nothing
i'm showing that thing just to just once
we crack that we've cracked it
yeah okay so what do you think about the
experimental does it kind of make you
understand like the concept of nothing
coming from something like does it make
you think like okay it doesn't really
yeah at the beginning of time it's a
thought-provoking thing so yeah yeah
okay what do you think about experiment
uh philosophical question so basically
what's your name
brian yeah because okay
do you want me to talk in the box would
you want to open it i'm gonna open it
okay
so this is the particle that started the
whole universe okay are you excited
yeah wait wait where is this color
nothing
okay okay all right okay yeah now
the scientists are telling us that the
whole universe came from nothing there's
nothing here
do you believe that no no
no why based on my religion as a
christian i don't believe
in science's philosophy on how the world
began so yeah yeah
yeah as a muslim myself is what i take
from science and stuff like that okay
but you if you're coming to me and
telling me nothing created all this
you're a bit crazy you know what i'm
trying to say yeah exactly
so like somebody that has that kind of
belief how would you describe in one
word like somebody that comes up and
says look here all this came from
nothing there's nothing
gullible if anything yeah but like it's
a person that doesn't base their
beliefs on yeah they're personal agendas
just to what the crowd says
yeah exactly exactly
she's got no okay guys i'm going to show
you
a few weeks ago me and my friend we
caught the particle that started the
whole universe
so we wanted to show it to you guys yeah
okay and don't worry it's nothing that's
going to explode or anything like that
but would you like me to open it would
you like to open it for us to discover
this depends on
cat experiment no no no no no no no it's
trying to catch up
can i also open it if you don't okay
okay
i'll open it up yeah okay it's not there
okay what's inside nothing oh
okay what's inside the box nothing
somewhat
nothing yet so the sciences okay the
scientists are telling us that the whole
universe came into existence from
nothing
the same nothing do you believe that
bollocks
white [ __ ] i don't know because i could
start from i don't know yeah if i got
nothing yeah no no i think
i think about it it's nothing how could
something come from nothing
have you ever heard of seen anything
that came from nothing
no percy i have not physically like it
can't
you can't yeah yeah peter crouch
okay the particle that started the whole
universe everything inside as you can
see
me you and everything yeah it's in this
box yeah so we're going to open the box
and see the particle do you want to open
it
okay this is
what's in the box i can't see anything
in the box yeah
so there's he says the particle that
started the universe yes
yeah there's nothing in the box yeah
yeah well the scientists tell us that
the whole universe started from nothing
did you know that yeah okay do you do
you believe it started from nothing
like they're not really no you don't no
okay
so does anything come into existence
from nothing sorry not that i know it
physically no
yeah exactly so like you want to shout
out to the scientists out there who are
claiming that
nothing which is in this box there's
nothing this is what started the whole
universe
what would you what would you describe
such individual who said such a thing
in this context yeah i'd say that
scientists were wrong saying that
universe died from nothing okay why
because it physically can't have i
believe it physically can't have and
your experiments prove that it can't
have either so
okay so what do you think about
experiment has made you like you know
not that you believed it anyway yeah but
it's just made me doubt them even more
yeah
exactly because there's nothing in the
box guys
yeah the the we've got the particle here
we've captured it
that style
so we're going to show you and get your
feedback okay you're going to show me
we're going to open the box show you the
particle and get your feedback here
i promise you there's going to be
nothing in there like that nothing trust
me
okay so i'm talking are you an opening
i promise you i promise you okay this is
the particle that started the whole
universe
okay what's inside nothing
nothing particles air no no there's
nothing there we know
okay there's nothing in there so
scientists are telling us that the whole
universe came from nothing
[Music]
[Music]
you